i don't know if we're going to be able
to stay open until one now though
david and andrea were supposed to become
husband and wife today
but instead of walking down the aisle
they're walking through their options
after postponing their wedding until
next year
it feels very anticlimactic we got to
spend two years planning something
just for it to fall for at the last
minute their coveted date of august bank
holiday saturday had to be booked 18
months in advance
but they gave it up because andrea's
family live in canada
so couldn't have easily made it it's
just really hard to imagine
you know my dad not walking me down the
aisle or you know my sister not being
my maid of honor and my best friend from
back home over
known 27 years is you know not being
there for that day
just you know just wouldn't have been
the same and i just
can't imagine doing it without them
wedding bells would normally be ringing
out across the country today on what is
traditionally the busiest wedding day of
the calendar but not this year
nearly four and a half thousand weddings
that were due to take place today
have either been cancelled or postponed
taking the total number since lockdown
began
to over a hundred thousand for
businesses that rely on the wedding
season a time of bloom is instead one of
gloom
well we're surviving on our savings
isn't it weddings account for nearly a
third of sharjah's business
he had expected to do 25 this month but
he's only had one
we need the wedding industry to come
back so obviously until next year
do you think it will come back to be
honest with you
looking at covid then brexit then
we're in a recession which is gonna kick
in in six months time
because it's only in figures at the
moment so it's not looking
that good the current 30 guest limit is
a fraction of the numbers bhavna barrett
normally shoots
but the freelance photographer's next
job isn't until february
so on what should have been her busiest
weekend she's pondering the future of
her business
we do have work for next year but it's
going to be months before
we get to see any income you know so
what do i do between now and february of
next year
you know where you know how do i earn a
living
the sector's calling on the government
for more support and clarity on its
future
warning that without it a quarter of
wedding businesses will close
right now the wedding sector is being
excluded for things that already exist
that could actually benefit us
so for example the hospitality industry
is receiving support
um yet wedding venues are excluded from
that vat for example is a really key one
and as summer draws to a close it's not
just a lost day couples and businesses
are dealing with
but potentially a lost year iva bennett
sky news
you